chris carl chandler yeah there are 100
hunters behind you
and their mission is to successfully
hunt us down and kill us oh my gosh
whichever one of us survives the longest
gets a mystery prize
go whoa you got five minutes until the
hunters are unfrozen
get in get in i can't run in these heels
this was a bad outfit choice
i'm out go go go go go i'm going to
change my clothing
nice i'm just doing circles around the
hunters
i'm out stupid hunters time to go
incognito
all right what blends in the best ow you
punched my head off
hey look i'm blending in chris there's
nothing that blends
in boys i'm not ready i'm not ready
i'm skipping a few i'm gonna go tell
them hello 100 hunters
i have 15 iphones with me and if you
kill one of us we'll send you five
iphone 12s
i just wanted dinner with you man okay
okay here we go what the where did you
get aks what
i'm gonna go to some clothing stores
first and see if they're gonna try and
change their appearance
can you guys get out chandler chandler
let us out
i don't trust you guys now and since
there is a hundred of them and only four
of us i gave all the boys extra hp
where are you guys there we go right
here hey hey stop running i just redid
my fit i got jeans on
got a jacket backwards hat they'll never
suspect it oh there's a hunter there's a
hunter
oh oh two hunters just passed me they're
not gonna be in fine wood
maybe the hills yo they're beating me up
oh shoot i shot i
see you i love my hiding spot i was
trying to hide from a hundred people
where would i be oh a helicopter get
inside yeah all right air ones in the
air
chandler come up here go go go go go
they can't find us up here
they have helicopters oh shoot i do see
one
yeah chandler we got to get on the move
i'm acting incognito walking next to a
police officer excuse me sir i'm trying
to drive nice
oh one of them just drove past me you
could have won five iphones all right
i'm breaking into this car
i hope a hunter doesn't see me steal
this car
a hunter almost slammed into me oh
he's checking me he's checking me honda
behind us
bro hey that's him what what
garbage truck garbage truck on us
he's in green he's in green oh my god
i'm not good with controller
oh my god they're just hitting me with a
car and i can't get up
yo i i don't know this is a trap
oh thanks for the free car wow chris
just killed two people is there a way we
can open
this box truck up what we should do is
have someone drive it while we stand on
top of the aks
carl where are you i need help oh i
accidentally ran a red light in front of
a hunter
oh he hit me i'm getting open fired on
oh shuts in front of us
yo there's dude there's two of them on
top of a truck
oh no you're too close yeah someone help
jimmy i'm coming
i'm on the north side of the map someone
help me i think i found one actually
yeah that's right that's right j perry
you better j parry your butt out of here
oh god that is an explosive that is an
explosive
oh i just blew a sky high i'm dead
is this you yeah this is me yo i can't
blend in with society anymore
you blend in great oh god these on me
he's on me
blow him up throws too far out the
window how do i shoot it
i'm shooting at them they have sticky
bombs oh my god i'm going to die where
do
you where there's the jewelry store it's
carl all right i killed him widowmaker
what's this dude
i don't feel like a weenie no more on
top of this roof maybe
tell me where you are wait i need your
help i need your help it's near the
clothing store
right here right here on the left that
is him no i'm not him
rpgs he's in the alleyway next to the
jewelry store bro
i just blew up so many of them i'm going
to die
right here behind him up behind you i
have a gun trying to get in the car with
them
they're getting out i did it
i did it while you're conveniently
crouched behind that wall can i tell
them about the sponsor
yeah that's fine great because the
sponsor of this video is nordvpn
are you telling me there's a special
offer right now at nordvpn.com that's
crazy that's exactly what i was about to
say
nor vpn is super easy to use and has
fast and reliable connections all over
the world
if i want to connect to a server in the
uk bam i'm in the uk
even though i'm not wait a minute jimmy
i really like anime that are only
available in certain countries does that
mean i can set myself in japan
yep let's go whenever i need to hide my
location or mask my ip
i always use nordvpn and best of all it
comes with a 30 day risk free money back
guaranteed
let's go to nordvpn.com
mr beastgaming select grab the deal use
the code mr beastgaming and boom you get
a huge discount on your two-year plan
plus a free bonus
what is it you'll just have to go to
nordvpn.com mr beastgaming and find out
for yourself
i will just do this go to nordvpn.com
mr beastgaming use the code mr
beastgaming get your free bonus your
ginormous discount ginormous
and now let's go run away yeah we should
probably go chandler i need your help so
bad
i'm almost at the clothing store
chandler carl how are things going for
you guys not good
there's like 70 on me oh dear god 71
we're coming we're coming move out of
our way jimmy look there's a cat in the
game holy crap
hurry up guys wow there's a cute little
cat help me out
look at that i need your help stop
talking about a cat
oh my god jimmy yeah red car recovery
car it's going past those honest
do customs go driving into that do not
go driving into that
right there in that group right there
that giant group guys are gonna die i'm
gonna die
yo if you look at the top right the
hunters keep killing each other
jimmy help me jimmy
jimmy jimmy i'm coming they're just
ramming me
get back here get back here all right
i'm switching to nade launcher it's not
my fault if this hits you oh one run run
run
jimmy jimmy what the frick broke hey hit
a wall and bounce back that's not my
fault
he's at the apartment by city hall
no wait chris we should get out of here
because now they know we're here
dude little tell me what explosives got
him all right let's go
get us out of here
they shot our tires hold on get out get
out get out get out get out come in here
come in here i'll get air support from
the roof
wait i'm just climbing ladders on
accident i'm on the roof you're on the
roof oh oh they're on top of the jewelry
store on top of the jewelry store oh i
need help chris i need help
i got i'm gonna come back i got you
oh i got done by chris oh i flanked him
i'm going up top the jewelry store right
now oh there's one on the roof over here
i mean there was one on the roof over
here yo i see one i see one i see when i
see one
oh my god oh for the love of god oh the
humanity
blue car blue car uh heading towards
little soul carl let me know when you're
approaching i have the rpg ready i'm
right here i'm right here i'm right here
i'm right here i'm right here holding
clothing store binko clothing store near
um
did i blew you up you blew me up
chandler because chandler killed carl
and he's not one of the hunters he's
allowed to keep competing and we
respawned him where he died
we gotta get in cars hey going for it if
you die you die we can't keep all
respawning the ambulance come on we
gotta we gotta go for the ambulance now
you can drive sporadic and they won't
think anything
this is perfect chris we need to get off
this roof all right hold on let me
handle this real quick
at the top he's right at the top with an
lmg die die
they're up top this is lautering
everybody we gotta go we gotta go
yeah they're on top of your top and
jewelry hey chris chris i found a ladder
over here
oh no no no i didn't want to jump oh yo
i just fell in front of this guy
where did he come from you could have
five iphones i i'm leaving
you chris godspeed i'm holding off the
line
oh he's oh he's shot at me with the
machine gun he's across do you see that
boat right in front of us
go go go oh my god that's them oh there
it is
oh no they're chasing me what's up
[ __ ]
oh no no no no no no no chris help me
help me i'm just gonna dive bomb the
jewelry store okay
they're flying planes into me to try and
kill me get away from me
with this nade launcher you cannot hurt
me how am i not dead how am i not dead
how am i not dead how are we not dead
from all these waves bro
i'd be blowing up right now i'm taking
this motorcycle go go go go
oh oh i'm out oh i'm out oh ow all right
one's on a motorcycle going past the
jewelry store go go go go go go go get
me out of here
chris i never should have left i need
help i wish i could
get up get him ow someone help me
shooting him on the ground someone help
me
yeah i'm playing into one of them over
here oh i've got four thousand hp
no no no no no i'm ready ready let's go
go go go go go go go
here if you want i'm grabbing i'm one
shot shot one shot someone help me
get him get him uh no ah
yes i got him hello hi deb rosa
congratulations
i have five iphones and we are going to
ship them to you
thank you so much we're in such a good
spot don't go too far from the boat
because we might need to get back in we
can get on the roof oh
did you die yet no not yet i'm changing
my outfit i am now bald eagle man
i got one of them get wrecked nerd
you're bad
eagle man ain't playing no games carl i
see an airplane we can get
chandler come with me
i don't know how to use ladders since a
ladder killed you
give this ladder five iphones
how does this make you feel stupid it's
now you versus carl which one of you
will get the mystery prize it's gonna be
me
i'm just gonna keep boat in here
oh my god i'm in such a bad spot oh
dear heavens dude i'm in an all black
car
fully custom out yeah i'm in a pretty
cool looking car too
you want to meet up you want to meet up
oh delmont up here down they'll be here
hey i'll come to the pier
i'm on my way if somebody's driving down
the pier stuff
oh my god you don't live
no it was chris he's on the pier holy
cow i think they found me do you wanna
check the pier person on the airport
we're going backside we're going
backside you see his car
oh
oh my god oh yeah there's one with the
grenade launcher on the end of the pier
i'm seeing so many people going towards
the pier right now
there's like 20 people here dude
oh i shot myself hey this is me i'm in
the ice cream truck i see the ice cream
truck right over here
i jumped off i caught on fire oh he's in
the water
i'm at the very end of the pier there's
like a ladder on the other side
all right i'm on my way i have 10 000
where you at uh 18 000.
ow i'm getting shot your honor
no underneath the uh the roller coaster
i killed a guy he was on the roller
coaster wait where are we
i'm shooting i'm shooting okay i'm
coming towards you in a red car okay
okay okay i see
if you can't tell chris is lying to carl
chris really
strong beach on the beach chris chris
this is your time to shine
you're not lasering fast enough your
health is depleting
screw you nerd you're bad you don't get
it as long as that guy doesn't get it i
don't care where are you chris i wanted
to help you
i died that's so fun
carl do you hear chris yelling in the
other room yeah
because you just won oh here's your
mystery prize oh my god a box
it's five iphones the same as the
contestants what a surprise
all right goodbye